I don't wait what no that's wrong not
wrong hello and welcome to this video
playing drama the sooner we are common
drain you whoa what are you doing here
some kind of lets off British feel very
tempted to lash out here let's do it and
get something funky I don't know how how
gambling this actually is sometimes this
is not so bad yeah the thing is do a
play age for now or not and going for
going for broke it looks interesting
that too it may be placed before him
nope yeah thing is he has a clear screen
g3 pretty pretty quickly okay maybe that
was a little bit a little bit too much
still think it's kind of interesting
selfie the tech this
right h5 I don't get to have fallen
fortunately this should be three i can
probably take my queen takes and the
duck that night it's not bad on dark
squares maybe he's preparing that so
once you put this here I need to cancel
long short obviously doesn't work
anymore okay yeah maybe I have to do
this to irritate them a bit on the
queenside be 597 and 94 is not so easily
playable okay so we prepared that with
this I can actually try to put a night
on to f4 and this this could be
something yeah he is reacting to it to
this idea so maybe still night h5 I
wonder
no I played this house this is better
asking about that Paul and make night
before more problematic yes again this
is a good mood I think so yeah but night
h5 right this isn't so bad let's do it
he takes it and the Queen on h5 is
aggressive replaced now of course that
I'm taking or not yep until now let's
see this is probably good oh no then I
chief then the Queen's you form I can
also play at six and night h4 I wonder
that is an idea at age 4 or at this end
to my killing ok so I'm taking him yeah
this is some probably a good decision it
makes a spawn structure like like the
worst ever but it covers f4 and that was
probably important thing to do if i can
so long
please avoid pulled in a queen trade
a bit unsure about my precise move over
here okay until I'm taking too long
just keep an eye on on that pawn I want
to bring the night to e6 that would be
fantastic 2014 7 and then 96 it's my
trial not only six is covering g7 and
prepares to jump to c5 this is would be
great to get in
you could place c5 and probably play 96
anyway and it's an interesting move
before I play b6 myself
once in a while you really have a piece
that is the absolute backbone of your
position and I have one here the night
out for 9550 time morning probably
wanted that grade okay
you
scene with five or so Jake this nono my
night has no squares I the end just like
that okay that's the problem just oh
shoot literally that game up so I was so
happy with this concept and I think it
was pretty good come on land resign
that's a shame I always hated if you
really have an interesting idea how this
disposition is really interesting I mean
even though yeah okay the engine likes
white butter with I still liked it and
I'm not sure that the engine is actually
right here to be honest be six year
maybe I should have played b6 myself I
don't know I don't think I'm versi I and
I simply refuse to believe that sorry I
just have to play better from here that
must be okay for back it is always all
of the fortress maybe I had wanted too
much maybe with Queen 87 and attacking
this green a try the stand and move
that's probably correct yes I am very
close to a fortune see any way with
night coming to see five years yes
he only has weaknesses them and that was
probably too too ambitious down wanted
to play at five aji hi wow that's the
kind of move you don't play hit and here
he has the control Jeff now he's
entering and that's that I cannot calm
the Challenger that's a shame really
like it how and we like the way that
that panned out okay I could have taken
a 2 of course but I didn't want to
invest this time also i love this
position I mean this is just just a nice
position to have okay the engine wants
to go nitey six immediately and is 86
million this is actually a good point
yeah why do I have to play a six in this
position there's no particular reason I
have to take where the prior this is
dreadful this is this is down right
arrow on even though the engine just
gives our porn or so it's it's just
terrible and be 66 plate b6 myself but i
don't know i don't have the time for a
problem and so it is not probably enough
compensation that it's it's the kind of
work it's tricky to play obviously
[Music]